Tonight digging
deeper into the December 2020
Oval Office meeting
that sources
tell us
special counsel
Jackson and his team
has shown a renewed focus on.
Now there are two reasons for that first
we have the perspective
of someone
who knows
the cast of characters in the meeting
and has worked with many of them
over the years.
And secondly, it's
worth another look
simply because of how unprecedented
that meeting was in the Oval Office
in terms of what was on the table
and what followed just hours later.
The former
president tweeting, quote, Big protests
in D.C. on January six.
Be there will be wild.
Now, that tweet,
which would later be seen as Exhibit
A for allegedly inciting
the mob that day, now
looks like the action
he chose to take
instead The even more outlandish ideas
that were discussed during the meeting,
such as seizing
voting machines in the states
he lost and invoking martial law.
Former Trump campaign manager Bill
Stepien told the January six committee
he referred to those in favor
of such things
as, quote, team crazy
as opposed to team normal.
Representing the first group
that night, lawyers Sidney Powell
and Rudy Giuliani.
As a side note, a Washington
professional disciplinary committee today
recommended that Giuliani be disbarred.
Also, their disgraced general pardoned
felon and former national security
adviser Michael Flynn.
And Patrick Byrne,
a former dot.com
CEO on the so-called team
normal government
officials, including acting
chief of Staff Mark Meadows,
White House Counsel Pat Cipollone,
and White House lawyer Eric Sherman.
Now, Hershman,
during the deposition
to the January six committee,
Hershman describes
the meeting, including his confrontation
with Sidney Powell.
Over the 60
some election
related court cases,
she and her team had already lost
She says, Well, the judges are corrupt.
And that was like every one,
every single case
that you've done in the country
you guys lost.
Every one of them is corrupt.
Even the ones we appointed
I think that it got to the point
where the screaming was
completely, completely out there.
I mean, you got two people walking.
It was late at night.
It had been a long day.
And what they were proposing
I thought, was nuts.
Nuts.
And now it is also the renewed focus
of the man
who will soon have to decide
whether to bring January six
related charges
against the former president and others.
I want to get perspective now
from someone who was not in that room,
but is certainly familiar
with the players,
including the man
he once served as national
security adviser John Bolton.
Ambassador Bolton, thanks for being here.
What do you make of this latest
reporting that special counsel
Jack Smith is particularly interested
in that
that December 2020 Oval Office meeting
did that track with
where you think he may be headed
Well, it certainly sounds from all kinds
of reports,
including particularly
the one you just mentioned, that
that the scope of the investigation
very much centers on Donald Trump,
the events in the Oval Office,
the things that flowed from that, things
that led up to
it really all involve Trump personally.
So while there may be
a lot of defendants who get charged,
I think clearly Trump is in a scope now,
whether there's enough
to convince him and his team
that they should indict,
that's a different question.
But in terms of the investigation,
I think the focus is
is clearly more and more on Trump.
I want to play
what former
White House counsel Pat Cipollone.
He told the January six
congressional committee
about the cast of characters
who are in that actual meeting.
I just want to play this
I walked in,
sergeant, and
I saw Sidney Powell sitting there.
I was not happy to see the people
in the Oval Explain why.
Well, again,
I don't think they are providing.
Well, first of all,
the Overstock person, you know,
this was actually the first thing I did.
I walked in,
I looked at it and I said, who were you?
And he told me,
I don't think
any of these people
were providing the president
with good advice.
And
so I didn't understand
how they got in
I know former national security
official Fiona Hill,
who testified publicly
that you had major concerns
about Rudy Giuliani.
She quoted you as saying Giuliani's
a hand grenade who's going to blow
everybody up?
Does it surprise you
that these people were able
to get into the Oval Office
Well,
it's stunning that they did,
but no, I don't think it was surprising.
I mean, it
sounds like like the
the bar scene in Star Wars.
But but this was not this didn't.
This is not the first time this happened.
People random people had access to Trump.
I can tell you, on national security
matters, he'd hear something
from some member at Marla ago
or somebody
he had met,
you know,
in a rope line at an event
and would ask us, have you heard this?
And of course, we wouldn't have heard it,
but he would take it as true.
He gathered information
from all kinds of people,
whether they knew anything about what
they were talking about or not.
And it was a fundamental flaw
that many people in Trump's
White House tried to correct.
Tried to protect him
from from being put in contact
with people who endangered him.
When you put his his own
political viability in danger,
he just
resisted every effort of people
to help him out in that regard.
It is extraordinary.
I mean, especially with some distance,
it's even just weirder.
That you, as national security adviser
in the White House to the president,
would have to contend
with and navigate around
random people on a rope lines.
And, you know,
God knows who
who saddles up to him in Mar-A-Lago.
I mean, that's incredible.
Well, it's because
Trump prized information
that he thought was unique to him
because obviously he knows more
about any given subject
than any of his advisers.
And I'm sure he liked to hear from people
who reinforced his existing inclinations.
And in this scene in the Oval Office
that we've been talking about,
he had a collection of people
who who were totally divorced
from reality,
which is about where
he was at that point,
hearing what he wanted to hear.
And and that's that's
what kept him going.
If he had decided
it's a good idea to seize voting machines
using the military,
what would have happened
I mean, just in terms of the
how orders are executed,
I mean,
would that even have gotten out of the
would? How would that work?
Well, I think
there are
many people in the White House
who would have
who would have resisted that
to the utmost
until they were fired or resigned.
Then you have the question,
when that order goes to the Pentagon,
what happens over there?
It would have provoked
would have certainly risked
provoking a constitutional crisis.
And that that was something that
I think ultimately would
it would have would have
led to real problems with Trump thinking
perhaps he could hold on.
I mean, part of this is that Trump
never knew any limits.
And the closer he got to the end,
the more inclined he was to
to to push beyond any limits.
Anybody had done before.
And that's that's
what was at stake at that meeting.
I remember
after the former president's
June indictment
in the classified
documents investigation,
you said, quote,
It should be the end of Donald Trump's
political career.
Clearly is still going strong, you know,
as it is if he's indicted in this 20, 20
election investigation.
Do you think it would have
any impact on his support
I've now come to the
conclusion that the indictments
don't have any impact.
He's been indicted twice.
It hasn't had any impact.
If he gets indicted
two or three more times. Who cares?
I think the the real question
on what the election may turn on
is whether the special counsel
can get a trial date and hold it
before the Republican
primary process begins.
Trump
obviously will try and delay the trial
until 19 and until 2095.
Who knows how far he wants to delay it
Jack Smith has asked
for a trial date in December.
I think that's reasonable.
I think the public interest points
to an early trial.
If he can't get it
and this trial is delayed
until after the election,
I very much worry about what
the outcome would be.
Ambassador Bolton,
I appreciate your time. Thank you.
Thank you.